[موسيقى]
سلاح اثبت نجاحه منذ بدايه الحرب بات
ظهوره على شاشات الرادار يدفع بالقوات
الاوكرانيه لاطلاق صافرات الانذار بل
وتوجيه المقاتلات الاوكرانيه بالابتعاد
للحفاظ على سلامتها هذا طبعا يعود لقدرتها
على اطلاق صواريخ فرض صوتي
[موسيقى]
31 واحده من اسرع المقاتلات في العالم اذ
تصلوا سرعتها حتى ثلاثه الاف كيلو متر في
الساعه الواحده كما تحلق على ارتفاعات
عاليه عند تنفيذ مهام هجوميه او قتاليه
هذا الامر ابقاها بمامن من النيران
الاوكرانيه صممت مقاتله الميغا 31 لتكون
مقاتله اعتراضيه يمكنها التصدي لمقاتلات
او حتى قاذفات استراتيجيه على ارتفاعات
شاهقه يصل حتى اثنين وثمانين الف قدم
[موسيقى]
دخلت هذه المقاتله الخدمه في سلاح الجو
السوفيتي في عام
لكنها شهدت عده عمليات تحديث وتطوير
حولتها لاحدى اهم الطائرات الاعتراضيه في
الترسانه الروسيه حتى هذه اللحظه مثلا هي
المقاتله الوحيده المسلحه بصواريخ ار 77
وهي صواريخ جو جو فرد صوتيه مضاده
للطائرات معروفه لدى حلف الناتو باسم
صواريخ ارض
[موسيقى]
تم تعديل بعض طائرات ميج 31 لتتمكن من حمل
وا رقصه صواريخ جو ارض من طراز كنزال فرط
الصوتيه هذه الصواريخ التي الحقت خسائر
كبيره بالاوكرانيين بل ولعبت دورا حاسما
في تدمير جزء كبير من البنيه التحتيه لعدد
من المدن الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]